the one and only Tyler Perry is a heck
of a year your Hollywood Walk of Fame
the studio is opening yeah you're living
your best life yeah I'm feeling pretty
good
Tyler is worth more than 1 billion
dollars including this 330 acre studio
bigger than Warner Brothers Disney and
paramount studio Lots combined it's huge
yeah if I stop and take it all in I
think I would be somewhere in a puddle
of water distant tears because it's just
this is a lot he purchased the property
for 30 million in 2015 this weekend is
the official unveiling and big stars
will get to see the sound stages he's
dedicated to them how did you choose who
you would honor you know when I was at
Paramount I was walking through looking
at all the buildings there and none of
them are named after an african-american
I've wanted all these people who have
done so much incredible work in this
business to know that I see you we see
you we love you and we appreciate you
for Smithtown Jerry and Oprah I get an
opportunity to say thank you thank you
okay
this year Perry laid to rest his most
famous alter-ego medea retiring the
character and a 500 million dollar
box-office franchise she was based on
his mother
Willy Maxine who passed away nearly 10
years ago what would kill me Louisa mom
say about this she'd be crying because
they want to make fun of me that's why I
got skinned Tyler's gone from a rough
childhood
to the first african-american to own a
studio he's currently producing nine
shows including two new dramas all while
raising is now four year old son Amnon
this legacy will be passed on to him if
he wants it he loves to come on set and
say cut and
you know so I'm just watching them very
closely and I'm trying to keep Madea as
far away from his okay
[Music]